-As most Republicans
fully embrace Donald Trump,
others are trying
to have it both ways
by courting his base
while keeping Trump himself
at arm's length.
Meanwhile, Trump is
still trying to cover up
what happened behind
the scenes on January 6th.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
President Biden is currently
on a major international trip,
where he just completed
a G20 Summit in Rome
and then headed to Glasgow
for a conference
on climate change
and, as his poll numbers sag
here at home,
he seems invigorated
by the trip,
as evidenced by this headline
in The New York Times...
Well, I'm glad
you're having fun.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, we're all stuck here
with our weird aunt and uncle.
[ Laughter ]
"You kids want some dinner?
Well, how are you going
to pay for it?!"
[ Laughter ]
Biden's like a divorcée
posting Facebook photos
from a solo trip to Europe.
Next, he's going
to post a pic on Insta
from a gondola in Venice,
wearing a sun hat
with the caption...
[ Laughter and applause ]
But, hey, we've all been there.
You're stressed,
having a tough time at work,
so you grab a pint
of Haagen-Dazs
and you call up your best bud --
in Biden's case, Obama --
and say --
[ As Biden ]
I just need a reset.
And he says --
[ As Obama ] Uh...when I'm down,
I find it always helps
to do a podcast with, uh...
Bruce Springsteen.
[ Laughter ]
And then, you mutter
under your breath,
"Well, we're not all you."
[ Laughter ]
So you say, "Eff it."
You pack a bag.
You head to the airport,
buy the first ticket to Italy,
where you eat, you pray,
and, most importantly...
[ Laughter ]
Of course, when Trump went
abroad, it was more like...
[ Laughter ]
[ As Johnny Carson ]
Eat, pray, shove.
[ Laughter ]
Did you, uh,
did you like that one, Wally?
[ As Ed McMahon ]
[ Laughs ]
Yes, sir!
[ Laughter ]
-Also, I want to note that,
earlier I chose Haagen-Dazs
for that ice cream joke,
instead of a certain
Vermont-based ice cream company,
which has still refused
to respond
to my detailed request
for my own personalized
ice cream flavor,
called A Closer Lick.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
I guess, uh --
I guess our friends
at Ben & Jerry's
are laugh-tose intolerant.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Carson ] Laugh-tose,
laugh-tose intolerant.
[ Laughter ]
Laugh-tose intolerant.
Did you like that one, Wally?
-I don't want
to do this anymore.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hm, when did Wally
get so choosy?
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the point is
Biden is in Scotland
for a climate summit,
coming off a trip to Rome,
where, among other things,
he met with the Pope
for 90 minutes,
which, as far as anyone
can remember,
is the longest meeting
any sitting president
has had with the Pope,
especially compared
to Biden's predecessor.
-Tonight, President Biden
with a very busy first day
of his second overseas trip
ahead of the G20 Summit in Rome,
traveling to the Vatican,
where he had a lengthy meeting
with Pope Francis --
90 minutes in all.
-When President Trump met
with the Pope,
it lasted 30 minutes.
-I mean, I guess
it shouldn't be surprising
that Biden's meeting
with the Pope
was three times
as long as Trump's.
I mean, knowing Biden,
he puts in a good 40 minutes
with the barista when he pops
in to Starbucks.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ] Let's run it
through one more time
because I got to tell you,
grande and tall
both mean big where I come from.
[ Laughter ]
And Biden is
a practicing Catholic
and a man of deep faith,
while Trump probably thinks
stained glass
just needs a little Windex.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I can't even begin
to imagine what a meeting
between Donald Trump
and Pope Francis would be about.
[ As Trump ]
It's an honor to meet you,
you, Your Holiness, Mr. Pope.
[ Laughter ]
Can I call you Frank?
We love religion
and we love church.
[ Laughter ]
We love church.
Don't we, Frank?
The Bible is, well,
it's number one, isn't it?
That's what it's all about,
isn't it?
Isn't it, Frank?
I like the Old Testament
and, of course,
the gritty reboot,
the New Testament.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We love a reboot, don't we?
But I like the old.
You know who else I like
that was old?
Arnold Palmer.
[ Laughter ]
Met him at Augusta National
in '92.
Stay with me, Pope.
I was there --
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter and applause ]
I was there --
Do you need to translate?
How's his English?
I'll just plow through.
[ Laughter ]
I was there.
We invented the drink.
He couldn't decide
between lemonade and iced tea
and I said, "Arnold,
why not both?"
[ Laughter ]
And they go --
they go so great together,
just like the Old
and New Testament.
The Pope fell asleep.
[ Laughter ]
Someone wake up the Pope.
So, Biden is on a much needed
getaway, as his poll numbers sag
and Republicans continue
to coalesce around Trumpism
and the core narrative that
the 2020 election was stolen.
In Virginia, for example,
the governor's race there
is neck-and-neck, in a state
Biden won by 10 points.
The GOP candidate there,
Glenn Youngkin,
has tried to distance
himself from Trump,
while also keeping
his supporters onboard,
a task that got trickier
when Trump announced
that he would hold
a tele-rally for Youngkin.
Youngkin has said
that he has no intention
of participating
in the Trump rally.
-A lot of Republicans
would be thrilled
to be on a stage with Trump,
so close to Election Day.
Not so much in Virginia.
And it sounds like Youngkin
won't even get on the phone
with him publicly.
What's happening?
-No, Jim, he has no plans
to participate
with the former president
in that tele-rally on Monday.
He has long distanced himself
from Trump,
but engaged Trump supporters.
-The former president is doing
a tele-rally on Monday.
Will you attend and do you
welcome him to Virginia?
-Well, so I haven't been
involved in that.
The teams are talking.
-I'm sure they would love
to have you.
-I know.
-Would you like to do that?
I'll answer you in a second.
I've been out campaigning.
I'm not going to be engaged
in the tele town hall,
but we have more people
helping us
than you can possibly believe.
This is about unity.
-Yes, famously, that's what
Donald Trump is all about --
unity.
[ Laughter ]
If real estate
hadn't worked out,
he could've been
a couples' counselor.
"Have you tried a three-way?
I hear that solves
a lot of problems.
Let me just lock the door."
[ Laughter ]
Trump stoked a violent
insurrection
to overthrow democracy,
and oversaw a disastrous
response to a deadly pandemic,
among many other things.
You can't thread the needle
and have it both ways
by courting his supporters,
while also keeping him
at arm's length.
It's hard to say,
"If you like Trump,
you'll like me,
but I don't like Trump.
Also, elections are rigged,
so get out there and vote."
[ Laughter ]
Being a Republican
who keeps Trump at arm's length
is like trying
to make it 24 hours
without seeing any "Succession"
spoilers on social media.
It's not going to happen.
You know,
I didn't watch last night,
but, thanks to Twitter,
I don't have to.
Look, I'm not one of those
"No spoilers" people,
but just give me a day!
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday was Halloween and,
by the time "Succession" was on,
I was passed out on the couch,
covered in Necco Wafers
and Tootsie Rolls --
the only candy my kids
let me have!
[ Laughter ]
I tried to sneak
one peanut butter cup
out of the little one's bag
and he called me
a Reese's Piece of [bleep]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then, he slapped my hand
so hard,
I had to write
with my left one today.
Which is why the note I left you
looks like that!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Most Republicans are
full-throated supporters
of Trump and his assault
on democracy,
while others, like Youngkin,
are trying to pull off a con
where they tap into Trumpism
as an ideology
and court Trump's base
without standing next
to him onstage,
but one reason
it'll never work is
Trump always makes everything
about himself,
as he did yet again in response
to speculation from the press.
He issued a statement insisting
that he and Glenn Youngkin
are actually very good friends.
Cool, I'm sure Youngkin
is thrilled to hear that.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans in Virginia
have been trying
to appeal to Trump's base
without getting
Trump himself involved,
but he can't help it.
His next statement
is going to say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just another reminder
for Republicans --
no matter how hard you try,
you can never escape Trump.
You guys are like the people
who think Chucky's dead
because you threw him
out a window.
[ Laughter ]
"No need to look.
I'm sure the fall killed Chucky.
Now, let's move on
from Chucky the doll
and talk more
about Chucky's ideas!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Did the analogy get a little
too far away from us?
[ Laughter ]
On Fox News over the weekend,
for example,
Trump appeared
with Jeanine Pirro
for his regular rant session,
where she tried
to call him a kingmaker,
but accidentally
used the wrong term.
-My base has to turn out.
If my base turns out,
he's going to win,
and I hope they turn out.
I really want them to turn out.
And I think, if my base
doesn't come out, he can't win.
I think my base has
to come out very strongly.
-Do you see yourself
as a kingpin
for elections going forward?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, something has happened,
and this is not
from an egotistical standpoint.
-Yeah. I asked a question.
-It's a great honor
because it's never
happened before to anybody.
If I endorse somebody, they win.
If I endorse somebody,
they win.
I think I'm 148-2.
-You can't just make up
your own win-loss record.
[ Laughter ]
Otherwise, the Jets to be 7-0,
instead of 2-5.
Although, the Jets
did have a big win yesterday.
And, if I'm being honest,
the last thing we need
at late night right now
is the Jets being competitive.
This is already
a pretty troubling time
for our writing staff,
in regards
to easy New York punch lines.
I mean, the Knicks are
in first place.
LaGuardia's getting redone.
It might be nice now.
[ Laughter ]
De Blasio's leaving office.
Even Pizza Rat went
on a plant-based diet
and he looks great now.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Here's me earlier today.
"Handsome jacked rat?
Exclamation point."
[ Laughter and applause ]
All I'm saying is
it's going to be touch-and-go
until April for New York jokes,
until the Mets come back,
although, knowing the Mets,
they might not come back.
Where are you guys?
It's opening day!
"It is? Since when does baseball
start in April?"
Since for always!
[ Laughter ]
Also, Jeanine, I'm pretty sure
you meant to say kingmaker,
which is a good thing,
not kingpin, which is usually
reserved for criminals.
[ Laughter ]
That's a very revealing slip.
I'd say it's Freudian,
but with you,
it's probably Franzian.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Groaning ]
-Whoo!
-[ Laughing ]
Who groaned?
[ Laughter and applause ]
We spent a long time today
talking
about a joke we're not going
to do, which is
Trump being insulted
that he was called kingpin
because he wouldn't like
the superhero villain Kingpin.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
Never caught Daredevil.
[ Laughter ]
As we speak, he's still trying
to hide records
about what happened
on January 6th
from the committee investigating
the insurrection
and, this weekend,
we found out more
about exactly what types
of records he's trying to hide.
-They include files from his
top administration officials
Stephen Miller,
Kayleigh McEnany,
and then, White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows.
Among Meadows' papers
are three handwritten notes
specifically about the events
of January 6th.
-We did not know
what records had existed
in the Trump White House
before last night.
In this court filing,
very late at night,
the National Archives
puts out a list
of more than 700 pages,
itemized, saying,
"This is what Donald Trump
wants to keep secret,"
and they really gave details
that we didn't know.
There are these handwritten
memos, or handwritten notes
from Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows,
specifically about January 6th.
There are call logs
and switchboard call logs
about calls to President Trump,
to Vice President Mike Pence,
leading up to,
about January 6th.
These are
very specific things --
White House visitor logs,
White House call records.
-Personally, I'm shocked
the Trump White House
even had any records at all.
I assumed that place was like
a Radio Shack in a zombie movie.
[ Laughter ]
Most of the call logs
probably just say...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And there's an obvious reason
Trump wants to keep
those records hidden,
as we've discussed before.
Trump and his cronies
had a detailed plan
for overturning election results
and they tried to execute that
plan and they almost succeeded.
It wasn't an impulse or a whim,
it was a plot.
Trump even had a lawyer
who wrote an instruction manual
for overturning the result.
When Vice President Mike Pence
declined
to follow through on the plan,
that same Trump lawyer
told Pence
the violent insurrection
was his fault,
as the insurrection
was happening.
-The Washington Post
is now reporting that,
in the middle
of the Capitol invasion,
as rioters were overrunning
the building
and chanting "Hang Mike Pence,"
one of former President Trump's
attorneys emailed
a top aide
for the then-vice president,
blaming Pence for the violence
because he refused to block
the election certification.
-And, when that aide described
the attack
as a siege in an email,
Trump attorney John Eastman
wrote back...
Eastman essentially
blaming Pence
for what happened
on January 6th.
-Even as the rioters are
rampaging through the Capitol,
threatening to kill Mike Pence,
one of Trump's cronies
was still pushing Pence
to overturn the result.
It's like telling a Walmart
greeter to stand their post,
even as a mob
of Black Friday shoppers storms
through the front doors.
"Hello! Welcome to Walmart.
Happy shopping!
Help me! I need backup!
I'm under siege!
I need extraction, you know!
Oh, crap!
Oh, this is just
a happy face button!"
[ Laughter ]
But that's because the big lie
that the election was stolen
and the idea that the
insurrection was justified
are now a key part of Trumpism
and the core of the modern GOP
and, no matter how hard
they try,
the Glenn Youngkins of the world
can't run away from that.
Last week, far-right crazy
person Marjorie Taylor Greene
[ Laughter ]
even suggested that
the insurrection was justified
by the Declaration
of Independence.
-But the real truth is
the communist revolution
that the Democrats funded
and waged
every single day
and every single night
in American cities
all across our country,
you see, that was an attack
on innocent American people,
whereas, January 6th was just
a riot at the Capitol.
And, if you think about what
our Declaration
of Independence says,
it says to overthrow tyrants.
-I don't know.
You think Democrats are tyrants?
Have you ever even seen
Chuck Schumer?
Tyrants don't wear their glasses
that far down on their nose.
[ Laughter ]
It's like he's staring at a menu
at a diner on the
Upper West Side for three hours.
[ As Schumer ]
We're very close
to coming to agreement
on whether to split
an appetizer.
"Sir, the restaurant
is closing very soon."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Schumer ] Okay, okay, well,
just leave me here in the dark.
I've got a New York Times
crossword puzzle
I've been working on since 1985.
[ Laughter ]
The GOP has embraced Trumpism
fully and completely,
whether they brag about it
or whether they try to play coy.
He sowed a violent insurrection
to overthrow democracy,
but Republicans
are still onboard,
which means he'll almost
certainly try
to do it again, making him a...
-Kingpin for elections
going forward?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.